let's talk about the shanks Iceberg and
I'm not talking about shipping these two
characters the iceberg that contains the
greatest Mysteries and theories about
red hair Shanks the most legendary
character in one piece in case you don't
know the iceberg video format is a
system of levels starting with popular
and mainstream theories and Mysteries of
a certain topic the stuff at the tip of
the iceberg everyone knows basically and
then you move deeper and deeper towards
the wildest and darkest theories that
the internet has to offer starting with
tier one now we all know that Goldie
Roger is the one who set off the great
pirate era however Shanks is just as
responsible for launching the events of
the series even the Luffy's following in
the steps of the first pirate king his
actual goal is to reunite with Shanks
and return the straw hats and so the
whole series has basically been leading
to the point where Luffy is a powerful
enough pirate to meet Shanks once again
but what has Shanks been up to in the
meantime well our first stop on our icy
tour of Shanks fan theories brings us to
the town that we see in chapter one of
one piece Windmill Village over the time
skip we learned that Makino the
bartender at the local bar was pregnant
and had a baby who's the father well our
money is on the bar's regular checks and
this next one is also a bit of a
softball Theory but they don't call it
tier number one for nothing well we're
still here above the surface of the
water so this idea is pretty much on the
nose we're going to make the Bold
statement that Shanks wants Luffy to
become the pirate's king after all he
inspired him gave him his fruit
sacrificed his arm for him and gave him
his hat Because he believes that Luffy
is the one who will become the pirate
king and find the one piece pretty
straightforward so let's go underwater
and onwards to tier number two as we
climb below the depth we bring our
submarine to the subtext of the story
starting with the idea that Shanks is
evil yeah the opposite of what we just
said Shanks has had some Sinister
ulterior motives all along after all he
is super mysterious and has had meetings
with the gurus known villains of the
series so Shanks must be evil and not
only is Shanks evil but another popular
fan Theory says that he's actually the
final boss of One Piece overall what a
twist it would be if it's not emu or a
kainu or Blackbeard at all but instead
Luffy's final obstacle in reaching the
one piece will be his own Mentor the
person that he's been looking up to
since chapter 1 of the entire series and
here's another great conspiracy you know
that Shanks has the craziest haki that
we've seen in the entire Series in
chapter 1 after losing his arm he uses
conkress haki to get the lord of the
coast to flee but surely his Armament
and observation hockey are strong enough
to have avoided having his arm bitten
off in the first place and so this
Theory says that Shanks lost his arm on
purpose because that way Luffy would
feel guilty over what happened and would
continue to feel driven to chase after
Shanks on the journey to becoming pirate
king I'd write that pretty likely still
so let's descend to tier number three of
the Shanks Iceberg and now we get some
really obscure facts things that we
would never see if we had stayed on the
surface facts like this shanks's sword
is named Griffin after the mythical
creature we're not sure what the origin
or the great of the sword is but it's
perfectly capable of clashing with
whitebeard's Supreme grade blades and
this next one is huge film red spoil
isn't coming by the way but this theory
is all but confirmed after the latest
one piece movie in a short clip it's
heavily implied that gold D Roger found
Shanks as a baby in a treasure chest
likely on God Valley the home of the
Celestial Dragon and His World Noble
status would also explain why Shanks is
able to demand an audience with the guru
say and might even explain why he was
able to put an end to the Marine Ford
war in case Shanks doesn't turn out to
be a Celestial Dragon though don't worry
we have a theory for that too because
with us continually finding out that
certain characters such as Trafalgar D
water law are secretly these the fan
base guesses that just about every
character could be a secret member of
the d-clan and Shanks of course is no
exception being one of the most powerful
and significant pirates in the world
plenty of fans think that he might be a
d as well and arriving at tier number
four we're almost halfway to the bottom
of our Iceberg what kind of wild Shanks
theories will lie in store for us here
oh by the way if you want to see more of
these Iceberg videos make sure to
subscribe and let me know which one
you'd like to see next okay so there is
a lot of mystery around what shank's
true goal is what is he trying to
accomplish the reason that he wanted to
stop the war and stop Blackbeard's
Ascension is because like the guru say
he shares the goal of keeping relative
peace through the power of the world
being balanced between the world
governments the yonko and the
shichibukai that didn't exactly turn out
right then did it and so now I think
it's time to talk a little bit about the
inspiration for shanks's design and
character specifically the Norse god
tier because much like this God Shanks
has one arm and is renowned as a
swordsman Shanks a ship the red Forest
takes clear inspiration from Viking
designs and so it's for this reason that
it's heavily speculated that when the
crew heads to elbaf Shanks will finally
take a central role in the story as he
will be the warden of that island and
this next Theory says that Shanks didn't
just give Luffy the straw hat to
remember him by the straw hat itself is
an important piece in the puzzle of
finding the one piece or becoming Joy
boy after all we do know that Shanks was
given the Hat by Roger originally and
we've seen that emu keeps a giant Frozen
Straw Hat beneath marijua so could the
straw hat be more than just the straw
hats a piece of clothing which already
brings us to tier number five and now
we're starting to get a lot deeper on
this Iceberg so brace yourself because
things will get weirder from here on
outs because it may have looked like
Luffy eating the gomogomanomi was just a
simple accident but what if Shanks
actually fed Luffy the fruit on purpose
knowing Luffy's lack of willpower he
left this super valuable treasure out
and available knowing that Luffy
wouldn't be able to resist taking a bite
here which sounds wild but not nearly as
wild as this next one because many one
piece viewers think that the daily bag
fight will make its way back into the
story somehow because as you know while
the Davey backfired against foxy didn't
seem that significant to the overall
story what if there was a much higher
stake Stevie bag fight between the straw
hats and the red hair Pirates whether
it's a friendly match or a deadly series
The Daily backfight needs to come back
into the story or else the foxy Arc just
doesn't seem to fit into the story at
all and I would be a shame because it's
the only Arc I really don't like so far
but before we get into that in the
spirit of the holidays and eating great
food we can't move into the new year
without checking out this month's box
suit their snack boxes have become an
absolute monthly highlight for me
throughout the year although I did make
the mistake to share them with my
friends so now every time a new one
arrives yep all the best stuff is
already gone right away before I even
have the chance to get my hands on it
this month's theme is called Hokkaido
Wonderland in case you don't know
Hokkaido is the snowy most northern
island of Japan and I personally think
it has the best food in the entire
country unfortunately though a certain
someone stole the shimagai Naga milk
bushe that I was looking forward to but
lucky for me everything in this box
looks absolutely fantastic actually
let's uh check out these milk carito
chips
oh that smells like Christmas oh my god
oh those are so good well if you want to
treat yourself or a friend while also
supporting my channel use my code O'Hara
for 15 off your first boxu Japanese
snack box thank you boxu well how about
really wild conspiracies for a change
what if I told you that dracul mihawk is
living a lie while he does hold the
mantle of world's greatest swordsman
right now he outright refuses to duel
with the one swordsman who used to fight
him regularly Shanks now mihaw claims
it's because Shanks lost his dominant
arm and therefore can't keep up but if
Shanks can claim the status of a yonko
with his remaining one arm then perhaps
mihawk actually knows that he's plainly
outclassed by Shanks oh wait this might
be the most controversial one we have in
here and now our submarine is reaching
tier number six with this crazy Theory
shank's new you the truth about the Mika
fruits even though he told Luffy it was
the gumugumunomi he targeted the Marine
ship that was carrying it because he
knew how important that fruit was he
learned the truth of Love tale and the
one piece from Roger and knew that for
joyboi to return the Nika fruit had to
make its way back to the right person
and the Roger stationed crocus at the
entrance of the grand line to keep an
eye on any potential candidates for
joyboy entering the grand line and help
them find the right way remember that
crocus was the one who gave the log pose
to Nami and the straw hats and he's also
the first person to tell them about love
tale Roger then stationed Rayleigh at
the entrance to the new worlds helping
the next pirate king to get strong
enough for the second half of the grand
line and will you look at that Rayleigh
did help the straw hats reach Fishman
Island and also personally trained Luffy
for two full years and so lastly Roger
ordered Chang's with stealing joyboy's
devil fruit from the government and then
finding the right person to eat it oh
and here's another the popular theory
about shanks's true goal one reason that
he will stand in Luffy's way at the end
is because he acts as the guardian of
Love tale he has his crew stationed in a
new world specifically to prevent any
unworthy pirate from reaching the one
piece by accident or even not by
accident this next one on the other hand
comes from One Piece Film red once again
where a one-off line probably has
revealed shanks's true surname this
continues the tradition of One Piece
movies giving us big reveals such as
Stampede revealing that raftel was
actually love tail and that name is
figure lands now it doesn't seem like
the name figure land tells us too much
about Shanks or who he might be
connected to the gurose is speculated
that utta is a figure land as well which
would in turn likely connect this family
name to Shanks given that it came from
the godosei is this another hint that
Shanks could be a Celestial Dragon and I
do hope that you brought along something
warm like your code because it is
getting kind of cold down here at tier
level seven we're almost at the bottom
now and things are about to get really
crazy like Shanks has the power to see
the future and we're not talking about
simple Advanced observation hockey here
katakuri may be able to see five six
seconds into the future but we're
talking about seeing way ahead Shanks
warned Whitebeard not to let A's fight
blackbeards he warned the guru say about
a certain pirate and when he saved Kobe
he told him that the moments he bought
had changed the future so what if Shanks
wasn't speaking figuratively here but he
can literally see far ahead into the
future and since we're asking some
really deep questions here why was
Shanks in the East blue to meet Luffy to
begin with well according to this theory
he had planned to give the Nika fruit to
Ace insteads while he was in Windmill
Village he'd originally arrived to find
Roger's son thinking that Ace would grow
up to become the future pirate king
following in his Father's Footsteps
however he then had a change of heart
when he happened to meet Luffy who
shared the same secret dream as Roger
either that or Luffy just ate it by
accident and that's how the entire story
went and speaking of people's dreams we
also have to talk about Blackbeard as
well because this Theory suggests that
Blackbeard was the one who gave Shanks
his scar throughout the story Shanks has
worn many people how dangerous
Blackbeard is pleading with whitebeards
probably the gorosei and More in order
to get people to take teach seriously as
a threat and despite how much Shanks has
wanted to stop the threat of Blackbeard
it hasn't stopped his meteoric rise to
power Blackbeard is now actively seeking
the keys to reach the one piece which
means it's only a matter of time before
these two yonko will clash and if
Blackbeard were to kill Shanks
especially before Shanks and Luffy are
able to reunite it would be one of the
most heartbreaking moments in the entire
series and it would give Luffy the
ultimate motivation for taking down
Marshall D teach okay but if you thought
things were insane so far now that we've
reached the bottom of the iceberg things
are about to get really wild here on
tier number eight these are the wildest
changed theories on the internet now one
famous Theory you might have heard about
Shanks is that he's actually the son of
Roxy's back but we say that's nonsense
in fact Shanks is just a distraction
from rox's real son buggy and hey I mean
it's Oda Anything Can Happen also why is
shanks's hockey so strong that he can
make a marine Admiral Retreat from miles
away well that's because he's a hockey
man who ate the hockey hockey fruit of
course this theoretical extremely
overpowered devil fruit gives him the
ultimate command over every type of
hockey Armament observation and
conquerors and gives him the power to
trance any other devil fruit user
because as we know hockey beats devil
fruit and here's another incredibly
unlikely Theory not only is Shanks ad
he's also the son of emu the secret king
of the world government he didn't make
an appointment with the godosei because
he's a Celestial Dragon he did it
because he is the Celestial Dragon and
the heir to the empty Throne not only is
Shanks at the top of the pirating world
but he's also at the top of the world
government now this would definitely
give Credence for for him being the
final boss of the series but uh let's
say the evidence here is lacking and so
yeah this was an entire Iceberg all
about Shanks but you can check out the
truly gigantic Iceberg video covering
all the crazy one piece theories I could
find by checking out this video right
here thanks for watching